Na polske ličke primude,
da imamo pravna pravila,
koji imaju polređenost
u kulturnisani države.
I povenuli smo dva osnovna
principa kulturnisani države
koja su pozvana čeo subordinacija
i koordinacija.
Subordinacija i odnos nadređenosti
i podređenosti.
Tu imamo državne grane
na različitom stepenu vlasti.
A kod koordinacije
imamo isti stepen vlasti
i imamo saradnje.
To je ono što smo u prošlom puno radili
i gdje smo sve zaustavili.
Sada idemo dalje. Kada je reč o ljudima?
Krenut ćemo sa ljudima
da vidimo koji to ljudi rade,
šta rade,
kako rade i kakav je njihov odnos.
prema državi kao poorganizaciju.
Dakle, državu kao poorganizaciju
ne čine svi građani,
ne čini svojstavništvo.
Taj državni aparat čine
samo neki ljudi. Ti
ljudi ti čine taj državni aparat,
oni se nazivaju državnim službenim licima.
Dakle, to su ljudi
koji rade u ime za račun države.
E sad,
tim državnim službenim licima se
daju određenom prostoru.
Dakle,
imate potređeno državno službeno lice,
dakle da rada neki posao
i taj posao predstavlja njegovu nadležnju.
Ja se budim dakle
da vam što jednostavnije objasnim.
Ne da se držim tih definicija izučbenika,
nego najprostije je moguće
da vam objasnim.
Dakle, uzmeš neki posao,
daš ga jednom državnom službenom licu
i kažeš evo ti na radi to,
to je tvoja nadležnost.
E sada, postoje dve vrste nadležnosti u
principu i ova treća nekakva funkcionalna,
to je uopšte nije zakonska kategorija, ali
se često spominje, pa ćemo nju objasniti,
Prisutna je naravno u radu državnih
hordana, ali nije zakonska kategorija.
Da krenjemo od stvarne, dakle,
ako uzmete recimo jednog sudiju
koji je državno službno nulice,
jednog narodnog poslanika koji je državno
službno nulice, da li oni radi isti.